welcome back to the david patten show
benjamin dickson filling in for David
while he is away filming with Joe Rogan
be sure to watch his episode with Joe
Rogan later on today also this is my
birthday
Oh turn up turn up go to my YouTube
channel and subscribe to my youtube
channel it's just kind of a birthday
gifts for me this next clip though man
Dave Rubin sir something's wrong with
you and the audience you'll understand
what I mean by listening to this clip
take a listen and it was totally
respectful and then the media frames it
like Oh even Budaj edge gets a standing
ovation at Fox News scary right-wing
conservative evil Fox News and it's like
well I could tell you that I've been
traveling the country for the last year
and I meet conservatives and
right-leaning people everywhere who know
I disagree with them on several things
some of them disagree with very personal
parts of my life actually and I find
them completely respectful and open and
decent all the time and yet it's the
people that are constantly preaching
tolerance and diversity and telling me
how wonderful they are and how horrible
everyone else's that are often the most
angry and mean and disrespectful so it's
a weird situation we're in so anyway so
I'll talk to two Crowder about that so
let me place this in context I actually
know the people conservatives who
disagree with him on his sexual
orientation that mean he didn't
specifically say it there but that's
what he's talking about like there's
there's an entire I mean most
conservatives particularly evangelical
Christians people in the audience for
the places that he goes and speaks you
know the intellectual dark web is
riddled with people who believe the
LGBTQ community is going to hell I know
them because I you know I come from the
Baptist tradition the black Baptist
tradition but homophobia that knows no
race right it homophobia doesn't
discriminate but but the point is is
that I know these people and Dave you
know these people and what you're doing
is you're making excuses for them much
like Candace Owens like you and Candace
Owens are two peas in a pod in my
birds of the same feather flocking
together because both of you have been
willing to betray who you are and what
you are for a very lucrative paycheck
because I'm sorry I could even watch I
could look not to psychoanalyze Dave but
I could watch when he said the word the
phrase something very personal to him
that actually hurts him and you know you
know when you think about like you know
maybe maybe I shouldn't feel empathy for
him because you know he's selling out
for money just like Candice Owens but I
felt a moment of empathy there because
really for his paycheck he's having to
go on stage and speak to people who no
matter what think he's going to help he
has to sit across the table from ben
shapiro of ben shapiro and ben shapiro
you know looking at him saying yeah
you're disgusting because you're gay you
know in his head thinking that right or
at a minimum maybe maybe ben shapiro
doesn't go that far
right but at a minimum is gonna lie yeah
you know i believe that you shouldn't be
able to get married right so take it you
know so how are you you know how do you
want to wrap it those people aren't not
tolerable they are in they have a level
of intolerance that is the baseline it
is it's like the very that's their
starting point and for dave rubin to
provide cover for them particularly for
something so personal to him really just
shows like how far money you know
honestly i have no other way to explain
it except the checks must be great over
there i mean i mean look at the work
that candice Owens is putting in right
now she's her her latest thing is
undermining the documentary the
documentary on Netflix
sorry not a documentary but the movie on
Netflix entitled when they see us
talking about the Central Park five who
were wrongfully accused won't fully
imprisoned and finally exonerated of any
crime she's doing the work right now to
say that it's all a lie and the
Democratic Party is just using this
movie to try to to persuade and to
manipulate the feelings of black people
right so you have people
very very committed to their role in
sustaining this white male Christian
power structure that Bill O'Reilly
described and this this the Christian
power structure that condemns the LGBTQ
community and the and the white power
structure that that wants to maintain
its grip you know people who are
committed to that and their commitment
to that I honestly think it just has to
be because they pay better over there on
the right you know the rest of us on the
Left which both of these people were
Dave Rubin used to be on the left
Candice always used to be on the left
and you can't say that the justification
for them going over to the right was
because the left was intolerant when
you're going over to a community of
people who reject your very existence
you can't say that Dave but what you can
say is that they pay better on the right
that's all the time I have for you today
bonus show is coming up we're gonna talk
about a couple of great stories and
thanks for letting me hang out with you
David will be back soon be sure to check
him out on Joe Rogan's podcast take care
of one